[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 2 février bienvenue dans
le journal de la rédaction de tv 78
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale voici
les titres de cette édition
l'information a été rendue officielle
dans l'après-midi à trappes l'élection
municipale de 2020 a été annulé par le
tribunal administratif de versailles à
l'irs avait fait appel mais si le
conseil d'état confiant de la décision
ses comptes de campagne seront rejetées
il sera rendu inéligible pour une durée
d'un an
les réactions à suivre il n'y aura pas
de record de rendez vous pour la
première vaccination en ile de france
annonce hier de l' agence régionale de
santé après les retards d'acheminement
des doses la campagne va donc pour voir
se poursuivre normalement où en est-on
dans les yvelines marion chin ali
directrice de la délégation
départementale de la rs est notre invité
et pour faciliter la vaccination la
municipalité de saint germain en laye a
mis en place cette initiative des taxis
gratuits pour les seniors qui se rendent
au centre de vaccination
une convention a été signée avec
l'association des taxis de la ville
et puis nous parlerons tout à l'heure
d'une initiative à montigny le
bretonneux qui a débuté deux semaines
dédié à l'orientation des jeunes
une édition en ligne mais aussi en
présentiel
l élection municipale à trappes est donc
annulée le tribunal administratif saisi
par othman nasri principal représentant
de l'opposition a rendu son verdict
annulé l'élection d'ali rabais ce
dernier devra rendre son écharpe
tricolore
une peine d'inéligibilité d'un an est
également prononcé des décisions qui
s'accompagne d'une validation du rejet
des comptes de campagne et reproché à
lies rabais d'avoir utilisé son
association kurde sera pour promouvoir
son image pendant la campagne et pendant
l'entre-deux-tours entraînant ainsi la
confusion auprès des électeurs le
principal intéressé a d'ores et déjà
annoncé faire appel du verdict auprès du
conseil d'état contacté par nickel et
demi d'euros ils ne considèrent ils
considèrent à ne rien avoir à se
reprocher eh bien je suis très surpris
par la décision du tribunal
administratif qui contredit les
conclusions de la rapporteur public qui
avait plaidé totalement en notre faveur
et dans le cadre de fêtes contradiction
entre le rapporteur public et les juges
du tribunal adminstratif moi je donnerai
le dernier mot qu'au conseil d'état qui
est notre parole d'apple c est pourquoi
je fais appel officiellement auprès du
conseil d'état qui lui verra dans les
mois qui viennent pour dire si cette
élection doit être annulée ou pas quoi
qu'il en soit je suis serein je n'ai
toujours été plus de ma relation
trappistes elle est claire et
n'utilisait pas pourquoi j'ai été élu
pour mettre en oeuvre quel projet 80 il
voit la qualité de notre travail avec
l'ensemble de mon équipe depuis
maintenant huit mois et on continuera
sur le même rythme dans les mois qui
viennent et quelle que soit l'issue du
monde lui qu'on fait n'est pas à la fin
on sera pas trop crappy fuir le même
bilan mais l'appel étant suspensif à
l'irs avait restauré en poste jusqu'à la
décision du conseil d'état qui pourrait
intervenir avant l'été
écoutez la réaction d'hotman nas roux
conseiller municipal d'opposition à
l'origine du recours au quai par michael
et demi d'euros le tribunal
administratif de versailles et vient
confirmer aujourd'hui ce qu'on répète
depuis des bras ce qu'on disait avant
même l'élection à savoir que monsieur
rabais a triché durant cette élection
n'a pas respecté les règles électorales
et fait inquiétant pour l'avenir de la
ville
contrairement à ce qu'il dit son
problème il est mobile avec la justice
commission des comptes de campagne que
les magistrats qui sont a également
saisi le tribunal après
htc compte et contrairement à ce qu'il a
dit parce qu'il n'a cessé de mentir aux
trafics
le tribunal a déclaré aujourd'hui que
les comptes avaient été rejetées à lui
ce titre que les comptes de campagne
n'incluait pas des dépenses électorales
qui est un manquement grave aux règles
électorales
et c'est en cela que la l'élection est
annulée mais également conservé déclaré
inéligible et donc il lui appartient de
s'expliquer il ya des procédures en
justice
jusque là on a attendu tranquillement ce
jugement quelqu'un ait pu être les
insultes j'ai été traitée de donald
trump de trappes mais moi je respecte la
justice je respectais vue autre réaction
à vous proposer celle de l'ancien maire
de trappes jusqu'en 2020 et guy
malandain il a été à la tête de la ville
pendant 19 ans aujourd'hui dans
l'opposition il n'exclut pas de se
représenter en cas de nouveau scrutin
une revanche contre ali rabais qui fut
son adjoint durant le mandat précédent
il a été joint par mélanie poker le
droit doit être respecté et en priorité
les respecter parce qu'ils ont des
mandats électoraux et donc les décisions
du tribunal prouve que monsieur rabais
n'a pas respecté le droit et vu le
comportement qu'il a eu samedi lors du
conseil municipal où rien n'est pris les
critiques permanentes sur ce que j'avais
fait avec mes amis dans le mandat dans
le mandat précédent
c'est bien que tout cela fait cette
annulation de l'élection municipale si
elle est confirmée pourrait également en
rebat les cartes au sein de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
qu'en pense le président de la
collectivité voici sa réponse au micro
d'astrid bergère il faut quelque chose
de vrai vous savez il ya le marketing
des candidats exagère toujours un petit
peu chaque année mais là on est plus
dans n'est plus dans l'ordre les règles
en dehors des règles c c'est vraiment
des techniques que de pressions de de
maquillage des informations de
d'utilisation de 2,2 de moyens qui sont
qu'ils sont illégaux puisque c'est pour
ça que la justice est intervenue là on a
dépassé
je veux dire un affranchi
l'infranchissable avec monsieur rabais
mais en cas de nouvelle élection le
président de saint quentin en yvelines
espèrent un plus large rassemblement la
tête de la ville toutes sensibilités
politiques confondues
on sait ce qu'il faut pour travaux le
tout c'est que il faut trouver des
moyens il faut que la il faut que la
nouvelle équipe qui pendant sept mois
cette collectivité soit cette trappe
il faut qu'elle il faut qu'elle ait le
soutien des puissants aussi actuel
département la région en 50 1 50-1 fait
50 % quasiment du moyen de trappes donc
il faut que tous ces gens là que qu'ils
soient de gauche ou droite mais qu'ils
aient cette volonté de travailler
ensemble et puis dernière réaction à
vous proposer celle de philippe
benassaya député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines celle à
laquelle appartient trappe l'élu de
droite apporte son soutien à celui qui
est également aujourd'hui son suppléant
à l'assemblée nationale autre menace
trop j'ai suivi son recours juridique
est exclu
son action pour pouvoir faire éclater la
vérité puisqu'il ya quand même il y
avait quand même pas mal pas mal de
problèmes sur la tête de dali rabais et
j'ai suivi les suisses en sait jamais
simple d'aller voter
quel que soit le camp politique c'est
cessez jamais simple parce que on fait
revoter la population moins un an ou un
peu plus d'un an après les élections
donc il faut remobiliser dans les deux
camps c'est pas évident d'abord pour le
maire sortant parce que il commence une
action municipale et elle est annulée
pour les faits graves dont on a parlé un
instant que dans l'autre camp il ya une
remobilisation à effectuer c'est pas
facile aussi pour othman al-othmane nasu
voilà pour ces réactions à l'annoncé de
cette décision du tribunal administratif
de versailles pardon je vous le rappelle
si vous nous rejoignez l'élection 2020
l'élection municipale de trappes annulé
à l'irs avait annoncé faire appel auprès
de cette décision appel du verdict
auprès du conseil d'état
alors que plane la menace d'un nouveau
confinement pour freiner l'épidémie de
kovy 19 la campagne de vaccination elle
se poursuit ce mardi la haute autorité
de santé
elle devait valider l'utilisation du
vaccin à d'astrazeneca en france après
ceux de finder but one tech et de modern
art où en est-on dans la campagne dans
les yvelines on en parle avec mario de
chine à libon soir qui est avec nous par
visioconférence directrice de la
délégation départementale des yvelines
de la rs ile-de-france l' agence
régionale de santé et déjà cette bonne
nouvelle annoncée par la rs
ile-de-france irl annoncé lé reste qu'il
n'y aurait pas de report est de
rendez-vous dans la région pour une
première injection de vaccin en février
contrairement à ce qui avait été annoncé
la semaine dernière à la suite des
retards de livraison des doses comment
expliquer que les délais vont finalement
pouvoir être tenu alors écoutez pour ça
on a fait un inventaire précis des
rendez-vous de primo vaccination qui
avait été pris par les différents
centres via d'octo libre et puis avec un
travail de recensement qu'on a fait
auprès des auprès des centres et donc
sur la région on a à peu près 29500
rendez-vous de primo vaccination qui ont
été pris pour la semaine prochaine et
donc du coup on nous a annoncé la
livraison de 12 mille doses de pfizer et
20 mille doses de moderna et donc nous
allons pouvoir réaliser avec avec ses 32
mille doses au final l'entièreté des
29500 rendez vous sur sur la primo
vaccination dans les centres de
vaccination pour ce qui concerne les
yvelines on est autour de 3850
rendez-vous qu'on va pouvoir maintenir
et donc ne pas décaler donc sur le sur
le mois de février on a compris pour les
primo injection et du coup pour les
deuxième injection les rendez-vous vont
être décalé de quelques jours
c'est ça alors pas du tout pour les
deuxième injection fait tous notre enjeu
c'était de pouvoir sanctuary zélés
deuxième injection
et donc c'est bien pour sanctuary zélés
deuxième injection qu'on avait quelques
difficultés sur la primovaccination donc
on aura bien
entièreté des deuxième injection qui
vont être réalisés le 8 pour les centres
de vaccination qui ont démarré le 11
janvier
et puis elles continueront les semaines
suivantes sur le 15 février le 22
février etc
et ces deux là seront bien sanctuary zay
ce sont les doses de primo vaccination
en fait qui vont être réduites et qu'ils
ont on va devoir gérer au fur et à
mesure en fonction des arrivées de
pfizer veut moderne
donc si on élargit le spectre on a
appris aussi dire que 100000
primo-injection au niveau de l'île de
france elle est réalisée en février 200
milles deuxième injection
vous avez parlé des objectifs dans les
yvelines là depuis le début de cette
campagne de vaccination combien de
personnes ont pu être vaccinées dans le
département
alors aujourd'hui on est à plus de 24
mille personnes qui ont pu être
vaccinées dans le département
et sur ces 24 mille personnes on a à peu
près 14 mille personnes de plus de 75
ans qui ont pu être vaccinés
si on le rappelle la vaccination est
ouverte aux plus de 75 ans mais aussi ça
s'était dans un premier temps aux
résidents et personnels des ehpad aux
professionnels de santé aux pompiers et
aux aides à domicile de plus de 50 ans
et donc on le disait aux personnes de
plus de 75 ans en plus aussi des
personnes qui présentent est des
comorbidités à haut risque alors mario
jean alio au 18 janvier il y avait neuf
centres ouverts de vaccination dans les
yvelines
on va voir la carte s'afficher avec à
des villes concernées notamment à mantes
la jolie
les mureaux rambouillet il y aussi des
centres de vaccination vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines à
montigny le bretonneux à poissy à saint
germain en laye où on avait pu faire un
reportage ça c'est pour les centres
ouverts 3 devrait devait normalement
ouvrir aussi le 25 janvier au menu la
saint cyr l'école et à sartrouville en
fonction de l'approvisionnement à des
doses de vaccin est ce qu'ils ont pu
ouvrir ses centres aujourd'hui et non
malheureusement du coup avec les
annonces qui nous ont été faites par le
laboratoire pfizer on n'a pas pu se
projeter sur une ouverture de ces
centres on a beaucoup travaillé avec les
municipalités pour pouvoir quand même
construire un schéma qui pourrait être
activée dès que dès qu on pourrait mais
là pour le moment on va pas pouvoir
ouvrir ces centres je pense d'ici là
moindre la fin du mois de février au
regard des faibles doses qui nous sont
annoncés par le national donc en raison
des faibles doses excuses dans les neuf
centres ouverts déjà est-ce que ils sont
tous restés ouverts est ce que des
fermetures sont à prévoir ou pas du tout
non nous nos centres sont tous restés
ouverts
on arrive par du coût des consignes
strictes compassé que les centres
applique avec précaution et est vraiment
on a un gros gros travail qui est qui
est menée avec les centres que je
remercie parce que ils jouent vraiment
le jeu et c'est pas simple du tout dans
dans les périodes qu'on vit actuellement
mais du coup on arrive à vraiment
contenir ses rendez vous et à chaque
plat avancer progressivement par rapport
aux consignes qui nous sont passés par
le national et donc de pouvoir assurer
les primo vaccination et puis ensuite et
les deuxième injection sans difficulté
et donc sans annulation de rendez-vous
et sans avoir à fermer des centres une
dernière question sur cette thématique
de la vaccination et en chine ali on
disait tout à l'heure l'actualité du
jour c'est aussi on est en attente de
cette validation du vaccin astrazeneca
repas la haute autorité de santé st un
vaccin qui dit moins efficace que les
autres même s'ils restent plus efficace
que la plupart des vaccins contre la
grippe il peut se conserver plus
facilement au réfrigérateur et également
sur une plus longue durée
et ça a été annoncé hier par le porte
parole du gouvernement gabriela talent
les pharmaciens vont pouvoir
l'administré ça a été annoncé hier par
le porte parole du gouvernement
est-ce que de la vaccination fait par
les pharmaciens dans les yvelines ça
pourrait se voir des mois de février où
on n'en parle pas encore bah ça se verra
dès qu'on aura les autorisations
effectivement qui seront données pour ce
pour ce vaccin là et dès qu'on aura les
premières informations sur les dates de
livraison
ensuite si vous voulez tout ce tissu des
professionnels de santé que ce soit en
officine chez les médecins traitants on
a l'habitude de les mobiliser vite c'est
ce qu'on fait déjà pour la grippe et
c'est un dispositif qui est très
efficace
donc dès qu'on aura le go par les
autorités nationales évidemment pourra
l'appliquer de mettre en place dans une
toute dernière question matinée sur la
situation de l'épidémie dans le
département on relaie le lundi 1 les
derniers chiffres sur une semaine de
l'épidémie avec une tendance plutôt à la
hausse
telle est la situation globale dans les
yvelines et est ce que la circulation du
variant britannique s'intensifie dans le
département alors la situation globale
on continue la poursuite à la hausse
on n'a pas de décrochage de courbes avec
avec une montée fulgurante mais on
continue à voir une progression le long
pendant lente et est constante
on est ce soir à 195 cas pour 100000
habitants pour 100000 habitants par an
en termes de taux d'incidence on est à
67,1 % en termes de taux d'occupation
des lits drea en soins critiques par des
patients coville donc on voit bien que
ça monte ça ne baisse pas on est très
vigilant parce qu'en fait tous nos
hôpitaux commencent à être vraiment dans
une situation parle encore de saturation
mais quand même très inquiétante donc
donc voilà c'est c'est pas on n'est pas
submergés par la mer mais on surveille
cette montée des eaux qu'on connaît par
rapport aux variantes
effectivement on a de plus en plus de
situations qui nous sont signalées dès
que celles-ci sont signalés on met en
place un dispositif de tracy encore plus
précis et plus pointu que ce qu'on met
normalement sur sur les autres cas
qu'ovide mai mais voilà oui
effectivement le variant que soient
anglais au sud afrique en afrique un
parent circulent
sur sur la région ile de france et
circulent aussi dans les égouts merci
mario jean ali d'avoir été avec nous et
je rappelle que vous êtes la directrice
de la délégation départementale yvelines
de la rs ile-de-france l' agence
régionale de santé pour faciliter la
vaccination des personnes âgées est
justement la ville de saint germain en
laye a mis en place cette initiative
depuis une dizaine de jours des taxis
gratuits pour aller chercher des
personnes de plus de 75 ans afin de se
rendre dans le centre intercommunal de
vaccination de fourqueux une convention
en ce sens a été signée avec
l'association des taxis de saint germain
le reportage d'eléonore sinoquet et de
marines de la barre des vaccins c'est le
petit main qui a été donnée à la
convention signée entre la ville de
saint-germain-en-laye et l'association
des taxis de saint germain objectif
acheminer les personnes âgées de plus de
75 ans au centre de vaccination
intercommunal de fourqueux on souhaitait
faciliter l'acheminement des personnes
âgées que ce ne soit pas un blocage pour
elle de se rendre au centre de
vaccination
certaines d'entre elles n'ont pas de
voiture d'autres ont plus de mal à
utiliser les transports en commun on
voulait aussi faire travailler les
sociétés de taxis par l'association des
taxis ça faisait un ils ont beaucoup
souffert du but du confinement et la
situation actuelle donc c'était vraiment
un partenariat pour nous gagnant gagnant
mise en place depuis une quinzaine de
jours le dispositif vaxy propose un taxi
pour un vaccin
le prix de la course a été plafonné à 10
euros pris en charge par la ville
une somme qu'il faudrait doubler en
temps normal pour faire le trajet saint
germain en laye fourqueux mais lorsque
l'idée est venue les 33 chauffeur de
taxi de la commune ont répondu présent
c'était une évidence qu'il fallait être
se rendre disponible pour ce genre de
prestation voilà on vit un moment
exceptionnel nous tous
tout le monde donc un moment
exceptionnel actions exceptionnelles
rossi donc en tant que commerçant de la
commune c'était juste de bon sens
évidemment de participer à cette action
et puis tout le monde y est gagnant tout
le monde aide et puis on est dans un
dead et de fraternité alors direction
fonteneau le centre de vaccination pour
financer cette convention la
municipalité a prévu une enveloppe de
dix mille euros pour le moment seule une
dizaine de personnes sur environ 4500
saint germanois âgées de plus de 75 ans
ont utilisé ce service gratuit pour
aller se faire vacciner deux semaines
consacré à l'orientation des jeunes
elles sont organisées par montigny le
bretonneux jusqu'au 12 février une
édition présentiel et en distance yale
avec des ressources en ligne
la directrice du pôle jeunesse de la
ville détail le programme dans cette
interview express collectées par célia
400 go
[Musique]
c'est un accueil individualisé sur des
étangs de d'ouverture sur rendez-vous un
accueil individuel aussi pour recherche
d'établissements informations sur la
l'orientation à partir de la troisième
la réforme du bac et sur parcours su et
après à distance il ya aussi une partie
programmation avec une conférence sur
l'apprentissage mode d'emploi le mardi 9
février
il ya également plein de ressources en
ligne
ça s'adresse à tous les jeunes à partir
de la 4e et ensuite jusqu'à 25 30 ans
pour pour les jeunes qui qui sont
étudiants et qui veulent compléter leur
cursus est ce qu'on leur propose quel
que soit l'âge c'est de travailler
autour d'un projet c'est-à-dire de
relier leur choix à ce qu'ils aiment
faire donc là c'est pas forcément dès la
4eme choisir un métier mais au moins
d'identifier des des domaines
professionnels qui pourraient leur
claire et puisqu'on parle d'orientation
jusqu'au 5 février c'est la troisième
semaine de l'apprentissage dans
l'artisanat est organisée par la chambre
des métiers et de l'artisanat d'île de
france
l'occasion de découvrir les formations
en apprentissage proposé par les cfa de
la région
plusieurs événements sont d'ailleurs
prévus sur le territoire des yvelines le
programme qui c'est qui est à retrouver
sur le lien qui s'affiche malgré la
crise l'apprentissage est dans un bon
moment en janvier 2021 les effectifs des
apprentis ont augmenté de 2 5% par
rapport à l'année dernière
pleine semaine de l'apprentissage dans
l'artisanat le campus de l'automobile et
de la mobilité de guyancourt organisé
ses portes ouvertes c'était samedi
dernier un rendez-vous maintenu malgré
le contexte de crise sanitaire les
jeunes ont pu découvrir sur place les
formations proposées retour avec mélanie
poké et nicolas landry se renseigner sur
des formations découvrir des métiers le
prince
cible des traditionnelles portes
ouvertes au campus de l'automobile et de
la mobilité ce rendez-vous s'est tenue
malgré le contexte sanitaire les gestes
barrières et la gestion des flux des
visiteurs
celle avantages des journées portes
ouvertes en physique c'est de voir
l'établissement
les ateliers où on va travailler et
cetera c'est plus simple que le visio et
on prie on peut poser plus de questions
on peut rencontrer des profs qu'on peut
rencontrer les formateurs pouvoir
tellement de choses sur ce campus dédié
aux métiers de la mobilité quatre
organismes de formation le gard ac l'a
fort palin cm et le gnf à avec chacun sa
spécialité c'est important pour ce
public de pouvoir voir des
démonstrations de pouvoir s'en rendre
compte de l'environnement de travail qui
va les attendre pour permettre aux
parents aux futurs apprentis aux
personnes en reconversion de trouver
leur voie de s'orienter trouver la
formation qui leur convient dans
l'automobile la moto et le vélo fait
l'institut national du cycle et du
motocycle et spécialisée dans la
maintenance des vélos et des motos
plusieurs formations sont proposées
allant du ceap et au bts en passant par
le bac professionnel des cursus sont
aussi proposés aux demandeurs d'emploi
ou aux personnes en situation de
reconversion
on alimente de énormément de demandes
sur nos formations en moto donc en
général continuent sur la moto ils
viennent par passion c'est leur premier
objectif
ils veulent absolument découvrir la
mécanique mais la mécanique est vraiment
moto ou vraiment la passion de l'aluminé
et qu'annick vélo un jeune qui fait un
contrat d'apprentissage ou un contrat de
professionnalisation s'insérera beaucoup
plus facilement dans une entreprise à
l'issue de sa formation
si vous n'avez pas eu l'occasion de
venir le samedi 30 janvier une visite
virtuelle permet de découvrir les
formations à distance sur le site
internet du campus les automobilistes et
les piétons les auront remarqués à la
nuit tombée certains passages piétons
d'elancourt sont équipés de petites
lumières bleues cela concerne cette rue
aux abords des groupes scolaires depuis
2019 la ville les déploie dans un
objectif sécuritaire meilleure
visibilité pour les automobilistes mieux
guider les piétons des lumières à
ampoules led une durée de vie de 5 ans
111 nouveaux éclairages vont être
installées à partir de mars et jusqu'à
la fin de l'année sur 22 passages
cloutés toujours à proximité des écoles
et des zones accidentogènes
coût total de l'opération 66 mille euros
et puis le sport et du football pour
refermer ce journal avec la douche
froide pour les joueurs de conflans le
club est éliminé de la coupe de france
sur tapis vert après décision de la
fédération française de football les
yvelinois s'était pourtant qualifié au
7e tour de la compétition après l'heure
victoire dimanche 2 à 0 sur vitry mais
la présence sur le terrain d'un joueur
suspendu a motivé cette décision
il ya donc désormais plus aucun
représentant yvelinois en coupe de
france de football
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité dans un instant ne
manquez pas le 7-8 culture nouveaux
numéros présentés par justin à brasier
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]